bonjour à vous patrick ferrasse merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
les rebelles éthiopiens du tigre et donc
qu'ils avaient avancé ces derniers mois
dans les régions voisines de la mara de
la farce on serait en train de se
replier donc vers le tigre et pour
ouvrir selon leur porte-parole une porte
à l'aide humanitaire est-ce que l'aide
humanitaire finalement c'est l'unique
motivation de ces rebelles oui bonjour
non le ce pas l'unique eu raison de ce
retrait je pense que les deux
belligérants bien vu qu'il fallait faire
une petite accalmie dans kaunas aura
cité générer une accalmie un petit
cessez le feu
transitoire et je pense que ça ne durera
pas très longtemps
le seul mouvement de retrait on l'a vu
ça fait déjà plusieurs jours que ce
qu'il est évident sur le terrain et donc
évidemment le type élèves retombe dans
ses frontières si l'on peut dire la
région petit graille mais il reste
énormément de problèmes à résoudre et
donc à bien mais tu vas devoir laisser
passer l'aide humanitaire si l'on peut
dire mais rien n'est résolu et après une
année après 14 mois de guerre on est
toujours au même point de départ que aux
3 4 novembre 2020 alors parmi les
problèmes ou la libye
l'aspect humanitaire selon l'onu le
conflit a fait plusieurs milliers de
morts plus de 2 millions de déplacés
plongée des centaines des milliers
d'éthiopiens dans des conditions proches
de la famine que sait-on exactement sur
cette situation humanitaire notamment au
niveau des chiffres bons et les chiffres
sont difficilement vérifiables si l'on
peut dire et on peut se fier aux nations
unies si l'on peut dire mais je dirais
même plus largement que ce que vous avez
dit ce n'est pas seulement la raison
petit graille qui te touchés par cette
nécessité d'avoir de l'aide humanitaire
c'est aussi la région afar et la région
amara qui sont donc le tout à fait sous
le joug que si l'on peut dire de à bien
mettre toujours au niveau de la de
l'ethiopie même si le tigre est
complètement à part si l'on peut dire
mais ces trois régions qui sont
fortement touchés donc voyez les
chiffres sont énormes et il faudrait en
considération aussi bien les régions
amara cafards et jusqu'à quelques jours
il ya quelques jours les tigres étaient
toujours en région amara donc voyez
la situation est dramatique et les
pragmatiques ce blanc pour le tigre
avait donc la bière mais de la devoir
faire un gros effort si l'on peut dire
pour les humanitaires enlevés en
direction du tigre haye mais aussi pour
la région afar et amara alors on l'a vu
son retrait annoncé par les rebelles
tigréens est un préalable qui a été
posée par le gouvernement
d'addis abeba pour entamer des
négociations et de leur côté les
rebelles il demande en retour de mettre
fin à je cite au siège humanitaire du
tigré est ce qu'une sortie du conflit
peut être amorcé vous pensez
moi je ne pense pas de ce blanc parce
que si vous regardez ce que de brionne
donc le patron du tpf a demandé en
écrivant secrétaire général des nations
unies il a demandé qu en même temps
c'était humanitaire arrive puisque avait
fait le premier geste sinon prirent mais
c'est simplement un premier geste et la
demande est ce que le tigre est ce soit
par exemple dotées d'une no fly zone
c'est à dire qu'une zone de contrôle
aérien de tout ce qui se passe sur le
tigre à dire qu'on ne puisse pas survolé
le tigre est comme ça et il a demandé
aux nations unies d'imposer un embargo à
l'ethiopie à l'erythrée vous imaginez
que ces deux raisons la à sont
pratiquement inacceptable par addis
abeba et à mon avis de bressols ne sait
aussi et on sait aussi que la chine
comme la russie bloqueront toute demande
de résolution dans ce sens là oui je
pense qu'on est donc plutôt dans une
barque et demi à ce petit cessez-le-feu
qui va durer quelques semaines et je
pense que le combat reprendre assez
rapidement
globalement c'est un conflit qui restent
difficiles à cerner faute de
communication dans les zones de combat
de restriction au sidaction journaliste
est les deux parties revendiquent en
tout cas des avancées des victoires que
sait-on réellement sur ce conflit qui
dure depuis un an
disons que ce qu'on sait que dans le
dernier mois sous les ya à peu près un
mois addis abeba était à portée de fusil
si l'on peut dire des tigres rien et il
ya eu ce mouvement de repli qui a été
entamée parce que la danse aujourd'hui
mail est entamée il ya plusieurs
semaines si l'on peut dire et en même
temps la bio mais des partis
à la tête de ses troupes je pense que
c'est à ce moment là qu'il ya dû y avoir
un deal entre les deux leaders ce soit
ben yahmed comme des brics yonne pour le
tpf pour arrêter un petit peu les
combats qu'elle nie et puis que l'aide
humanitaire puisse leur arriver en
zigzag tout ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui
c'est que les tigres et à se retire et
les études p1 qui se
reprenait vie ne reprennent que des fils
abandonné si l'on peut dire donc ya pas
de combat aujourd'hui les villes se
libère et donc les tigres n s'en vont et
l'armée éthiopienne réinvestissez ville
médias pas de combat et donc on est avec
une accalmie dans les combats et le rôle
à des états unis ont fait qu'il ya
plusieurs groupes alliés aux rebelles
qui ont signé un accord c'était à
washington
je pense que cette cette fédération de
petits moments a fait long feu si l'on
peut dire elle ne sert pas à grand chose
on a bien vu que même les oromos n'ont
pas servi à grand chose dans ce conflit
les tigres et je l'avais déjà dit sur
votre antenne reste tout seul si l'on
peut dire quoi être capable de faire
tomber à vie ahmed mais ils n'auront pas
besoin d eurobonds et encore moins des
autres petits partis voilà en revanche
la diplomatie américaine est à mon avis
présente elle vous l'avez montré dans
votre reportage et maintenant les
américains vont peser de tout leur poids
pour que habib ahmed satisfasse à l'aide
humanitaire l'arrivée de l'aide
humanitaire
la commission des nations unies aussi
qui devrait intervenir sur les droits de
l'homme et toutes être arriver à une
solution dans ce conflit mais j'y crois
pas beaucoup
l'onu qui a donné son feu vert à un
mécanisme international d' enquête sur
les exactions commises en ethiopie les
suites selon voie
il faudrait beaucoup de temps parce que
quand vous l'avez dit vous-même il n'y a
pas d'accès aux autres donc c'est
comment faire une commission denquête
quand vous n'avez pas accès aux zones
donc il faudra attendre bien longtemps
je pense pour que cette commission donne
des résultats prenant et percutant merci
beaucoup à vous pour cet éclairage
patrick ferrasse je rappelle que vous
êtes chercheur indépendant président de
l'association stratégie africaine
docteur en géopolitique spécialiste de
l'ethiopie